see I gotta believe this is part of
cabin in the woods otherwise this is a
dumbest [ __ ] family ever rather dead
people in that trailer what do we want
to do all right let's split up we're
gonna go check it out you two go back to
the other trailer there's a working
vehicle right there do we want to escape
now what do you want there to not be a
movie what I have to believe those
corporate dudes from cabin in the woods
are spraying gas in everyone's faces to
make them do dumb [ __ ]
[Music]
the strangers the strangers to the
strangers - is a sequel to the strangers
which I remarkably enjoy back is
watching this movie makes me question
whether or not the first strangers movie
was any good at all but 10 years ago
when I saw the movie once I actually
really enjoyed it could be crap now who
knows so this strangest movie this
family's dropping their daughter off at
boarding school which kind of looks like
Camp Crystal Lake perfect and then the
creeps from the strangers show up and
start killing people that's the facet
like that that's me cutting down the set
up because the setup in this movie was
boring [ __ ] the pacing dude what the
hell I get set up for a good horror
movie or supposed to set up the Tenjin
this movie just didn't have any tension
it was one scene where I was like this
movie would benefit from I don't know a
sneaking scene I think you know like a
sneaking mission like Metal Gear Solid
style ooh the creeps over there let's
not make any noise let's sneak out the
window and try to sneak past and beside
you like let's go let's go out the
window
let's project it to the psychopath so
they know that we're going out the
window instead of sneaking out quietly
like smart people and the movie just
loses me alright the brother in this
movie I don't want to talk [ __ ] and I
don't know how old he is but it's like
this dude is the joke that 21 Jump
Street jokes about it looks like a
thirty year old man they're all like
well when he goes to college next year
are you implying that he is 17 years old
you might be 17 years long I'm just
saying the dude doesn't look at when
you're casting for a 17 year old you
probably have a 17 year old who's Luke
17 he could be 45 long as he looks 17 do
did not this movie make so many horror
movie transgressions the kind of
reminded me of Texas Chainsaw the 3d
movie that came out a few years ago it's
actually a lot like that where they're
like yeah we're gonna take it back guys
you probably should have pushed it
forward this movie tries to cash in on
the whole 80s nostalgia craze going on
right now there is an 80s nostalgia
craze if you have not noticed I have my
thoughts about the 80s nostalgia craze
keeping it vague because I can make a 20
minute video on it basically people go
to movies as an escapism for escape to
escape the things that they hate seeing
in the world because generally speaking
the world just seems to suck but movies
are no longer the escape they used to be
enter 80s nostalgia it's that illusion
you can feed your brain to make yourself
go oh yeah I am back in childhood now
this movies like will have an 80s title
come on any time the psychopath kills
people the 80s music why dunno will even
have cheesy 80s horror movie zoom
eighties fades nailing it
like they don't know why 80s nostalgia
is a thing right now they're just like
what's the thing right now 80s that'll
be the hook it just comes across as out
of touch if not desperate because this
movie does not take place in the 80s
judging by the smartphones everyone was
rocking it very much takes place in the
21st century there are ways to do the
nostalgia thing and make it style is
there this one flew a little too close
to the Sun burned its wings just simply
but this movie should have at least been
some form of intense was not that I
wasn't ever tense there was nothing
intense about it so if you just strip it
down to the basics were the deaths
interesting now that were pretty basic
they just kind of died this kind of
seems like it could have been a fan film
or a tribute someone's like I love The
Strangers I'm gonna make my own
strangers movie and it comes out online
I'm like yeah well you know you try it I
get it but when it's a theatrically
released film and people have to pay
full ticket price you are open to more
scrutiny I'm just saying god I really
hated this movie yeah when they were
trying to do their trouble John
Carpenter right oh it's like a shitty
John Carpenter cover band The Strangers
whatever the hell the subtitle is it's
[ __ ] [ __ ] I guess and the
thumbnails in my videos a lot of people
are like oh I could tell what he thinks
about the movie from the thumbnail so
did you guess it hope so alright so the
strangers - have you seen it doubt it
but what do you think about it
hypothetically have you seen it what you
haven't what ever you think comment
below let me know or what's a shitty
horror movie that you remember you're
like nope should have come online for
free
Suicide Squad whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]